fantastic beasts the crimes of
Grindelwald is once again directed by
David Yates who's directed the previous
as well as a considerable amount of
Harry Potter films and is written by JK
Rowling herself and in this sequel which
is also a prequel Grindelwald played by
Johnny Depp escapes captivity and reeks
some havoc and Newt Scamander and his
buddies have to go up against him I've
reviewed every single Harry Potter film
in the franchise and I've liked all of
them I've found enjoyment in every
single one of them and I like the
previous fantastic beasts film my wife
is a gigantic Harry Potter fan she loves
it considerably more than I do and Harry
Potter is constantly a subject in her
house we really enjoy the books the
movies the lore the worlds built around
it we've gone to Universal and walk
through Diagon Alley many times which is
why it's so shocking to me that this
film was as bad as it was this is easily
the worst Harry Potter movie in my
opinion anyway I found the film
relentlessly boring which is something I
can't say about any of the other Harry
Potter films even some of the more
meandering ones at least had characters
I cared about and I'm not exactly sure
what happened this time around because I
actually really enjoyed the first
installment and I thought it was a great
stepping off point for something else it
didn't suffer from some of the problems
that other prequel series have suffered
from and I was excited to see where it
would go this one takes so many
characters and so many different
subplots and / stuffs the movie with so
much happening that it's actually kind
of difficult to follow my wife someone
who if you ask her like the most obscure
Harry Potter question about some random
thing that was maybe mentioned in one
paragraph of one of the books she knows
the answer and she had a hard time
following this film because it's just so
messy that's not to say this is an awful
movie there's some enjoyment to be had I
think David Yates once again did a
really good job directing the movie it's
visually stunning it's a really
beautiful film James Newton Howard score
as usual is euphoric a large majority of
the performances are excellent
especially Eddie Redmayne once again as
Newt Scamander
such a lovable cheerful character but I
think the real joy in this movie is Jude
Law as Dumbledore great casting great
performance movie needed a lot more of
him he's not in the movie too much which
I was disappointed by Johnny Depp is
Grindelwald though he didn't really
bring that much to the role it's not
that he was bad really the material he
was given there just wasn't that much
there to relish he has none of that
snaky slimy evil that ray Fiennes had
his Voldemort he's just a villain and
it's not that I find him miscast or that
they could have picked a better actor or
something I just don't really think he
had that much to do in the movie the
character was weak there wasn't that
much menacing about him the opening I
really enjoyed and I thought it set up
something kind of fun for him and they
just didn't really do anything with it
they had this great idea of Grindelwald
being able to control people and there's
nothing really done with it it's it's
very very limited there's so much they
could have explored with that ability
and it's kind of just like he walks
around and some people follow him around
and look to him for orders there isn't
that much depth to it and for a movie
called the crimes of Grindelwald he just
doesn't do that much to warrant that
title the real crime of this film is
that it's just so boring
and again I feel the need to reiterate
this is coming from somebody who really
likes these movies and books like my
wife was legitimately sad when we were
driving home like this was crushing to
her so I imagine this could be
detrimental for some Harry Potter fans
the universe in general and the fandom
in general because I can see some people
really loving the film because it
definitely acts like it's very epic it's
a long drawn out slowly paced film that
thinks it's a lot better than it is that
should have had another 20 minutes cut
out of it and 15 more passes before it
was complete but some Harry Potter fans
are really gonna like that and others
are going to hate it for some specific
choices it makes which I of course will
not spoil but they're the kind of
choices that make Harry Potter fans that
this universe back-to-front very
confused because certain things just
don't make sense and it's hard to really
justify some of the choices that are
made this is starting to feel like what
is bad about prequels where you start to
mess so much with things that suddenly
things you already appreciated and liked
don't work as well and that's sad
because there's a lot of actors in this
movie really trying and David Yates did
a good job directing it unfortunately
despite as big a fan as I am of JK
Rowling I feel like her script was
really the real problem here I'm gonna
give fantastic beasts the crimes of
Grindelwald a see guys thank you so much
as always for watching look forward to
more reviews very soon and if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes
[Music]